[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce rendez-vous photo qui
est devenu assez régulier grâce à vous
que chose merci de m'accueillir Patrice
vous êtes vous êtes photographe vous
allez exposer on parlera de vos
expositions dans quelques dans quelques
temps parce que c'est au mois de juin
mais vous êtes allé voir pour nous deux
formidables expositions dont vous allez
nous parler une qui concerne herving Pen
et une autre qui concerne Elliot R8 et
puis avec vous et bien j'accueille
Jean-Michel missry bonjour bonjour vous
êtes l'éditeur et redonne chef de deux
revues qu'on peut trouver sur internet
d'une qui s'appelle chains of grey
magazine et l'autre qui s'appelle
il y en a une qui plutôt au noir et
blanc et l'autre plutôt couleur on
pourrait dire ça comme ça c'est comme ça
et je devrais c'est venu de c'est venu
de je sais pas combien de nuances de
Grey non le où c'était avant
et donc
les photos noir et blanc en général ce
sont des nuances de gris d'accord c'est
un animal gamme de nuances donc le titre
est venu de la pas vraiment du film
c'est eux qui vous ont piqué le titre
après
Jean-Michel et puis et puis des revues
qu'on peut trouver en effet sur Internet
ben écoute Patrice merci de nous
accueillir déjà j'ai rencontré
Jean-Michel d'une d'exposition que je
faisais à Voisins-le-Bretonneux il était
avec un animateur du centre que je
connais bien Denis donc on peut le citer
puisque et moi j'ai on a beaucoup
conversé avec Jean-Michel pour parler de
son travail photographique et moi je lui
ai parlé du mien d'ailleurs
Jean-Michel m'a plusieurs fois
publié dans sa revue donc que je trouve
très intéressantes avec vraiment de très
très belles couleurs de très une qualité
de comment tu as de tirage
c'est pas c'est de la vidéo j'ai même là
si tu veux c'était une caméra très belle
qualité de de son travail donc il a un
travail vous êtes aussi photographe oui
vous avez été éditeur d'être en chef et
photographe
de 1986
quel numéro 70
3380 c'est plus vieux c'est le plus
vieux euh
et et comment comment vous êtes venu
l'idée alors de ces de ces revues parce
que Claude de dit il a raison il y a une
question de qualité d'image est-ce que
est-ce qu'on a la qualité de l'image sur
les sur les ordinateurs quand on regarde
de vos revues
oui j'essaie de faire le meilleur rendu
possible enfin l'idée du magazine est
venue d'une immense frustration
quand je regardais les autres magazines
photos qui sont du styles photos réponse
photo quand il présentait des
photographes c'était 4 3 4 pages avec
deux images un petit texte de
présentation et je trouvais ça
extrêmement frustrant
ce que j'aime quand je vois un livre ou
un magazine c'est me plonger essayer de
comprendre le travail du photographe ce
qui est absolument impossible avec les
autres magazines qui font des tonnes de
news qui mettent il y a plein de pages
de pubs qui arrivent à distraction et
c'est totalement c'est extrêmement
frustrant donc moi ce que je voulais
c'était faire des sujets très longs sur
les magazines la moyenne des sujets fait
à peu près 30 pages alors les longues
interview vraiment on entre dans le
coeur du travail des des sacs
photographes quoi c'est ça et donc la
plupart des photos sont présentées en
double page
avec la meilleure qualité possible
de façon à ce que c'est ce qu'on appelle
des MOOC maintenant des magasins de
livres et comment vous travaillez vous
allez à la rencontre des des
photographes de vos publier les photos
est-ce que c'est simple d'abord de
publier des photos il y a des droits il
y a des comment ça se passe
à l'époque j'étais sur Google+
qui avait peut-être la plus grande
communauté de photographes au monde
d'accord donc quand j'ai dit eu cette
idée de faire le magazine j'ai regardé
les photographes qui avaient été le plus
suivi
qui correspondait à au style de photo
que j'aimais
et j'ai contacté ces photographes quand
je leur ai dit je voulais créer un
magazine immédiatement ils m'ont dit on
est d'accord on va t'aider d'accord et
ils m'ont donné les photos ok il y avait
une attaque Alan chapiro
joaching gelard Giuliana gaspodaro qui
sont des maîtres de la photographie
maintenant et tous m'ont laissé publier
leurs images gratuitement et quand le
numéro est sorti ça a eu un très gros
succès au départ
et j'ai reçu ensuite je reçois une
dizaine de portfolio par semaine
maintenant des gens qui veulent être
c'est plus des gens qui s'adressent à
vous que vous qui allez à la pêche pour
chercher
très ou telle photographe et si je peux
rajouter un mot ce que fait Jean-Michel
c'est aussi la photo actuelle il va pas
piocher dans le dans le passé bien que
on est intéressé par le passé par nos
grands photographes que nous avons eu
actuellement c'est la photo actuelle moi
c'est ce qui me m’intéresse aussi c'est
de découvrir ce que font d'autres
personnes mon but c'est de faire
découvrir des nouveaux talents des
talents qui sont peu connus ou
moyennement connus et j'évite en général
de publier les photographes qui ont été
publiés partout d'accord oui donc voilà
la photographie
c'est une mèche que je trouve absolument
extraordinaire de tendresse de beauté
ça montre vraiment toute la qualité d'un
bon photographe qui arrive à trouver une
expression absolument incroyable
en passant comme ça c'est quand on fait
des photos de rue comme ça le principe
la principale chose c'est de ne pas
mettre tout de suite l'appareil photo
sous le nez des personnes qu'on pouvait
photographier c'est à dire qu'on
commence à leur parler alors sourire
d'accord
on voit tout de suite qu'il se
décontracte et quand on sort l'appareil
ça se fait d'une manière totalement
naturelle et il ne faut même plus
attention à l'appareil
mais vous disiez vous êtes évidemment
journaliste avec cette revue il y a
dans les photocopies comme celle-là
comme celle qu'on veut venir de voir
avant il y a un côté journalistique dans
ces photos reportage oui oui
la vie telle qu'elle est photographes
qui parlent en général deux ou trois
mois dans un pays où dans une région ou
dans une ville justement pour
s'imprégner de la culture de cette ville
ce sont des des photographes de voyage
qui ensuite change en photographe de rue
mais avec tout de suite on sent la
connexion qu'ils ont avec les gens qu'il
photographie
il y a beaucoup de portraits dans ces
photos
ça vous paraît
quand je publie un reportage de choisir
un thème
j'aime pas trop je n'aime pas trop quand
il y a des
photographes qui présentent 25 images de
sujets complètement différents
et c'est ce qui c'est ce qui passionne
en général les lecteurs j'ai énormément
de commentaires sur des gens qui disent
là on voit exactement on arrive à
imaginer la connexion des photographes
avec les gens qui le prennent qu'il
photographie et on sent qu'il y a
une compréhension totale entre les deux
ce ne sont pas des photos volées
qui
s'imprègnent du milieu dans lequel ils
sont et qui ressortent donc une sorte de
vérité quoi c'est ça qui est beau
moi je connais plusieurs photographes
connues comme Olivier culman qui fait
partie de tendance floues des choses
comme ça lui il me dit si tu veux quand
j'arrive dans un pays j'ai besoin
pendant une semaine de pas toucher
l'appareil photo et de comprendre
l'atmosphère du pays du pays pour
pouvoir
se précipiter malheureusement si la
plupart des gens qui aujourd'hui font de
la photo au smartphone mais je quand je
dis smartphone c'est un outil mais ils
sont là ils appuyent appuient mais
qu'est-ce qu'ils font de ces images
derrière alors que comme le dit très
bien Jean-Michel quand tu regardes quand
tu vas voir les gens tu leur demandes de
les photographier souvent tu depuis que
ton projet et là si tu veux ils vont ils
vont te dire d'accord vous pouvez me
prendre en photo moi j'opère dans 90%
des cas je photographie des gens dans la
rue c'est toujours ça je leur demande et
dans 90 % des à chaque fois ils me
disent ok alors voilà si tu veux c'est
ça il faut pas avoir peur d'aller vers
les gens malheureusement aujourd'hui
Lego comme ça
une petite réticence
le problème du droit à l'image qui était
quand même aussi
Claude parler de smartphone c'est à dire
que c'est vrai que on en parle souvent
quand on parle de photos ici mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a eu un changement
technologique très important dans la
photo
on est plus à l'époque de l'argentique
de développement dans le chambre de moi
quoi que certains photographes
continuent à utiliser ça quel est votre
analyse par rapport à ces changements
technologiques puisque vous vous dites
vous intéressez à la photo émergentes
donc je suppose à des gens qui emploient
des des matériaux très modernes il y a
énormément de photographes j'en ai
publié beaucoup d'ailleurs qui travaille
uniquement avec des téléphones
déjà la qualité des capteurs photos sur
mon téléphone il est devenu absolument
incroyable quand on prend le dernier
iPhone ou même les Huawei ou les Samsung
les capteurs sont une qualité incroyable
après c'est l'oeil du photographe
quel que soit la caméra qu'on utilise
c'est toujours l'oeil du photographe qui
prime mais peut-être que
je ne sais pas je pose cette question
mais peut-être que l'utilisation par
exemple des smartphones ou des dauphins
de téléphone d'une façon générale et
peut-être moins intrusive que que ce
qu'on avait autrefois avec un appareil
photo il fallait poser peut-être non non
Michel il a raison ce que disait
quartier Bresson photographier c'est
voir ce que les autres ne voient pas
bien sûr et donc ça
il a raison de dire c'est le photographe
parce que effectivement comme dit
Jean-Michel avec un smartphone tu fais
des choses remarquables tu fais des
tirages vous faites des choses moi si je
fais des choses c'est nul quoi
ne te considère pas comme nulle
j'aime beaucoup regarder les photos
parce que le mode maintenant
pratiquement qu'avec le qu'avec des
téléphones vogue avait fait un numéro il
y a quelques années uniquement avec des
photos faites avec un iPhone et le
louche
mais tu regardes bien si tu veux je à
l'heure actuelle j'observe un petit peu
comme je fais Jean-Michel dans la rue
aujourd'hui tu t'aperçois que tu as
pratiquement 3 à 4 personnes sur 5 qui
dans la rue en marchant regardent leur
téléphone bien sûr et ce qui m'amuse
beaucoup c'est de photographier les gens
en restaurant des couples qui sont assez
face à face
et je trouve que là il y a quelque chose
qui déraille ah oui il y a un changement
qu'est-ce que c'est important c'est la
personne qui est en face de toi ou le
marché sur toi c'est sûr que chacun et
chacun est concentré sur et puis après
on va donner des nouvelles sur les
réseaux sociaux pour dire voilà regardez
comment on était heureux au resto j'ai
mangé etc
il y a beaucoup de photos de de photos
de de plats et tout comme ça et les
restaurateurs sont pas toujours très
contents parce qu'il trouve que ça abîme
un peu la création
un mot sur leur comment on fait pour
pour trouver la revue est-ce qu'il faut
est-ce que c'est gratuit ou payant
est-ce qu'il faut s'abonner la revue est
payante elle est disponible uniquement
sur internet sur les sites du magazine
mais aussi sur les principaux kiosques
en ligne d'accord il y a y presque qui
vient de changer de nom je me souviens
plus du nom d'ailleurs de la nouvelle
version
caféine
il y en a un qui s'appelle presque
Reader
et donc et l'abonnement est de combien
l'abonnement est de 35 euros pour 6
numéros d'accord c'est dire son dérouler
qui sont bimensuels
et donc je fais en alternance
le magazine noir et blanc et le magazine
couleur alors le magazine noir et blanc
on rappelle le nom
et
pour les pour les photos couleurs
c'est formidable ce travail
j'ai déjà été plus du billet plusieurs
fois dans cette revue et je trouve que
la qualité si tu veux que tu vois à
l'écran te rapproche beaucoup du tirage
papier quoi parce que je trouve que
c'est c'est ça qui est intéressant alors
que souvent on voit des images qui sont
délavées qui sont où il manque une âme
dans cercle
alors on va maintenant parler de deux
expositions que vous avez vu
la première c'est cette déliother 8
alors 8 c'est un vieux monsieur c'est un
photographe américain donc 95 ans je
crois hein
on peut dire que c'est un des un
photographe américain qui fait qui est
parmi les plus importantes du 20e siècle
je pense que Jean-Michel était d'accord
tu es d'accord avec ça
un peu tout fait mais qui a fait
beaucoup de photos avec de l'humour
et beaucoup d'ironie si tu veux comme
quand tu vois cette photo de ce petit de
ce petit chien à côté du grand c'est la
peur de quoi
toute la série d'extraordinaire c'est
superbe c'est vrai que c'est très drôle
enfin il y a plein de c'est génial comme
alors moi cette photo j'ai voulu la
montrer parce que elle me rappelle un
petit peu la photo de la place de
l'Europe faite par quartier Bresson ce
monsieur qui saute si tu veux au niveau
comme on peut le voir là avec ce couple
d'amoureux donc c'est quelqu'un et cette
exposition se tient jusque
je crois jusqu'au 15 août monsieur
Maillot à Paris
et les divisée en deux si tu veux ils
ont fait vraiment une organisation qui
est parfaite c'est-à-dire qu'au premier
étage tu as le noir et blanc et au
rez-de-chaussée tu as la couleur qui est
beaucoup plus comment te dire
administratif quoi on a des photos de
grands personnages de de star de choses
comme ça alors qu'en gros c'est la photo
au premier étage c'est vraiment la photo
que que l'on doit aimer comme quand tu
regardes cette photo ne serait-ce cette
statue avec son antenne sur le toit donc
voilà c'est c'est assez amusant
je pense que le plus important qu'on
puisse faire en photographie et je vous
posais la question si vous êtes d'accord
avec lui c'est susciter l'émotion de
faire rire ou pleurer ou les deux à la
fois je suis d'accord
c'est exactement ça c'est exactement ça
c'est exactement comme la photo du
couple qu'on a vu
une photo n'oublions pas que
photographie veut dire écrire avec la
lumière donc obligatoirement tu tu dois
faire quand tu vois une photo tu fais
waouh c'est amusant de voir comment les
Américains mais maintenant ça arrive en
France déguise leur chien si tu veux
j'en ai vu avec des capuches dans le
faut arrêter de lui il est il est il est
américain oui mais il a beaucoup vécu en
Europe et notamment en France je crois
qu'il a vu la France tout à fait il a
fait partie de la de l'agence Magnum
aujourd'hui
bref
on va pas faire de l'épilogue et là je
crois bon c'est une exposition qui est
qui est assez
extraordinaire de voir l'oiseau avec ce
robinet et c'est à dire que
si vous aimez la photo il faut aller la
voir alors aller jusqu'à Paris puis
c'est très joli c'est ce musée Mayol
très bien alors à l'état supérieur
encore il y a des statuts de maillots
des tableaux donc on peut aussi
s'enrichir parce que il y a un lien
quand même toujours qui est qui est
assez proche entre la peinture et le
n'oublions pas que la peinture a changé
la photographie est arrivée quoi donc
voilà mais certains veulent même croyait
que la photo allait faire mourir la
peinture nous par chance non
les choses subsistent quand même donc
formidable exposition au Musée Maillol
et puis si vous allez si vous allez
faire un petit tour en Normandie à
Deauville à Deauville donc aux
franciscaines
magnifique lieu aussi un magnifique look
a été restauré qui était superbe et là
vous avez
Erwin peine qui est aussi pour moi fait
partie aussi des grands photographes du
siècle dernier
on fait lui et moi je crois en 2009 en
2009 donc à Manhattan
Picasso pour moi c'est la meilleure que
j'ai pu voir de Picasso parce que
regarde cette œil gauche qui te fixe
vraiment si tu veux plus intense
moi j'aime beaucoup son nom m'échappe
photographe d'Arles qui est beaucoup
photographié Picasso comment il
s'appelle le sinclairg oui
parce que tu vois c'est une photo que tu
présenterais moi je connais un peu la
vie des photos club mais tu présentes ça
dans un Photo Club on va te dire ah
ouais mais l'oeil droit il est dans le
noir on voit pas donc assis
je sais pas si j'en ai
que j'ai dit de cette photo écoute mais
parce que les gens cherchent
alors que
c'est de l'art et dans l'arbre
mais je vois qu'il faudrait voir le
tirage original parce que pour bien
comprendre cette photo et puis ça c'est
Greta
tout à fait et donc il y a beaucoup de
photos de stars il a fait beaucoup de
portraits il a fait des natures mortes
aussi il a fait beaucoup de photos de
beauté pour la publicité donc c'est
studio ouais et regarde cette photo de
Cocteau aussi je trouve que super belle
c'est vrai que il y a là pour le coup
comme vous disiez écrire avec la lumière
avec les ombres aussi quoi c'est ça et
il a fait une série de nuit aussi qui
est aussi remarquable mais
comment qui est dans l'exposition
avait explosé déjà je crois que c'est en
2017 au Grand Palais à Paris et j'avais
vu cette exposition c'est absolument
remarquable tu vois dans les photos de
nu qui l'a pris il a fait il a pris des
femmes
je dirais des femmes qui qui sont c'est
pas des stars des mannequins donc il a
pris des femmes et des amis vraiment en
beauté et il a fait beaucoup de studios
au musée européen de la photographie oui
hein qui est à Paris d'accord aussi que
qui a fait qui a fait dotation pardon à
la France de son patrimoine
photographique c'est aussi Michael Kena
si tu veux un jour on en parlera c'est
un photographe qui a phot qui a fait des
images je pense que Michel Connery
son travail sur Auschwitz il est comme
concentration qui est absolument
hallucinant
j'adore Michael Kena si tu veux et
toutes ces photos qu'il a fait sur
Versailles
puisqu'on parlait de lui donc c'est donc
aux franciscaines à Deauville et c'est
jusqu'à la fin du mois je crois que ça
se termine de 28 donc
et puis peut-être un mot d'une expo dont
on avait
parlé ici
puisque elle a lieu à Versailles
qui continue qui prolonger qui a été
prolongé jusqu'au 18 juin donc écoutez
franchement si vous avez un moment à
passer dans un lieu un prix qui a été
magnifiquement restauré qui est
l'hôpital royal construit par Louis XIV
c'est d'aller voir cette exposition
alors il y a des originaux mais il y a
des tirages modernes qui ont été refaits
à partir de ce que des négatifs que l'on
connaissait mais ce sont deux
photographes qui ne sont pas très
connues je dirais cartés moi
ensuite quartier Bresson mais c'est vrai
que l'article c'était un grand bourgeois
du début du 20e siècle et qui a fait des
choses qui sont surtout sur sa famille
ils ont vraiment très intéressantes et
puis je trouve que cartes s'était
ces deux personnages ces deux
photographes ont vécu pratiquement de
ils sont nés pratiquement la même année
ils ont travaillé
voilà et le travail il faut aller voir
cette exposition d'une part on est
dessus on est Sud débuté par le lieu oui
et d'autre part les photos sont
présentes
je dis aux gens aller voir parce que
c'est c'est vraiment très très bien voir
souvent des expositions j'essaie au
maximum
je reçois énormément d'habitations pour
les vernissages et malheureusement je
peux pas aller à tous s'il y en a une
que vous avez vu récemment quelques
conseils
récemment je n'ai pas vu beaucoup mais
la plus belle exposition que j'ai vu
c'était Sébastien Salgado d'accord
Monique il a été exposé aussi au Salon
de la Photo Porte de Versailles mais
cette expo c'était absolument fabuleux
alors Claude pour terminer il nous reste
plus beaucoup de temps mais on va on va
on va faire du teasing si je peux dire
sur vous vous avez beaucoup exposé au
mois de juin
plus que ça de mois de juin donc d'une
page d'expose au mois de juin à
Saint-Mandé puisque je suis président
d'un jury pour un concours photo des
clubs de la Défense nationale d'accord
de la région Île-de-France donc j'expose
pendant une semaine à Saint-Mandé c'est
un patchwork un peu de tout mon travail
et suis et puis il y a toujours le musée
de Rodez aussi qui alors avant c'est le
le foirail de du marché des sacs
les sacs est une ville qui qui a le
privilège d'accueillir le premier marché
de France de bovin c'est chez vous non
c'est votre région
mais j'adore cette région de quand même
tous les gens qui connaissent se sont et
puis tu es dans un pays vrai quoi
et donc je vais il y a une série de mes
photos sur le marché de l'ESSA qui vont
être exposés pendant trois mois et sur
trois ans d'affilée donc en extérieur
ils veulent agrémenter montrer ce qui
est le marché puisque aujourd'hui on a
plus le droit de faire des photos dans
le marché mais oui parce que il y a des
gens qui prennent des photos qui mettent
en doute le ce qu'on fait avec les
animaux
il y a le danger parce que tu as des
taureaux on sait jamais donc il y a eu
déjà qui ont été tués par des taureaux
donc voilà
alors ce marché se déroule tous les
mardis il se vend à peu près 2500 mètres
de bétail et il est divisé en deux de 8h
à 9h c'est la boucherie et de 10 et de
9h à 10h ce sont les broutards les
animaux qui ont les les prairies voilà
donc c'est ça
là vos photos là
on en reparlera on va faire une émission
un peu là-dessus sur ces expositions
Jean-Michel misery merci infiniment
c'était un plaisir
et bravo bravo pour ce travail que vous
faites et qui travaille à la fois
artistique et de découvert toi on peut
dire ça comme ça merci beaucoup et puis
à très bientôt pour un nouveau
rendez-vous photo
on établir un programme merci beaucoup
d'autres choses merci beaucoup
[Musique]